tonight at the Museum secret of the Tomb
okay oh my girls and I love these movies
so much
um okay so my co-star in this movie was
a monkey one of the very famous animal
actors called Crystal she's also in The
Hangover movies so Crystal
um I was really excited too it was very
famous monkey
um and I said would I be able to have a
photo with Crystal like a selfie
um and her trainer said not now she's
mentally preparing for a scene
and then I peek into her tent I was very
and I picked she literally was like like
she was a method actor preparing for the
scene going wow yeah I mean incredible
well don't mess with Crystal heard Meryl
Streep are preparing